MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Chrome Dev
Summit 2-- The Sequel.
MALE SPEAKER: We have a
bunch of Chrome developers
here to talk about the
work they're doing.
MALE SPEAKER: Today is all about
you all connecting with us.
MALE SPEAKER: Archimedes
said, "Use [? will change ?]
sparingly."
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Motion and animation
reinforce the idea that the
user is initiating change.
MALE SPEAKER: We created
a tool called Vulcanize.
MALE SPEAKER: As you've
all been sitting here,
we've actually secretly
been updating the website.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We also want
to make it easy for developers
to be able to use this
commission system.
AUDIENCE: Just a home screen
or "installs" my web app.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The best
part about the Chrome Summit
for me has been hearing
about these APIs right
as they're being worked
on, before they've actually
hit the ground.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
the big thing I get out
of the Chrome Summit
is a lot of validation
on the future of the web.
MALE SPEAKER: It's about getting
this really personal connection
to people working on Chrome,
being able to talk them
on a very personal level.
AUDIENCE: Is it going
to work on my device?
And how are we going
to get to that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: It's
an incredible time.
We expect over 5 billion
people in the next few years
to have a smartphone.
I think it's one of the
biggest opportunities all of us
will see in our
lifetime in computing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]